bonjour à tous
alors on va passer rapidement ce format
sur la présentation c'est un exercice
que j'aime pas du tout je suis le
président de la financière des paiements
électroniques c'est celle qui distribue
le contenu qu'elle puisse qu'on appelle
le compte en banque qui est accessible à
tous et qui est disponible uniquement
chez les buralistes
ils qui se voulait être une alternative
crédible au système bancaire existant
l'information je suis un ingénieur je
suis un ingénieur de deux technologies
en génie électrique intelligence
artificielle
c'est un diplôme que j'ai eus sans aucun
problème parce que je suis tout
simplement passionné depuis l'âge de 10
ans je pense que cette passion m'a
jamais quitté jusqu'à maintenant
et donc j'ai réussi à obtenir un peu à
monter tous les échelons sans aucun
problème j'ai une expertise en
technologie on l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure de la carte à puce les na'vi
gaulle les les passes les recharge
mobile et téléphoner bon tout au
téléphoniques et l'a dernièrement le
contenu quel est le confort banques
alors la première question à laquelle je
voulais répondre en fait je me la suis
pas posé tout de suite et je me la suis
pas posée quand j'ai conçu le comte
nickel mais c'est pourquoi j'ai fait ça
parce qu'on fait jamais rien on fait
jamais du social ou du solidaire ou de
l'humanitaire pour rien et est la
question que je voulais me poser et dont
j'ai fini par trouver la réponse je vais
poser bien après je sis sais quoi qui
m'a sais quoi qui m'a motivé là dedans
alors comme je vous l'aï dit avant je
suis je suis un serial entrepreneur ça
veut dire en gros quelqu'un qui réussit
ou même comme j'ai entendu un riche et
finalement une fois qu'on a réussi à
exister socialement qu'on a peut-être
trouvé à cette société qu'on avait
réussi en sait on sait pas grand chose
encore on sait pas prouvé grand chose à
soi même et je me suis dit c'est bien ça
devient un besoin personnel j'aimerais
j'aimerais réinventer un un vrai nouveau
modèle et je voudrais que ce modèle il
soit profitable parce que c'est un des
problèmes quand on parle de vie sociale
et solidaire c'est qu'on veut pas parler
du profit à un mot honteux qui ai
l'argent
quel profit quel investissement mais ça
je voudrais et moi je voulais absolument
qu'il soit profitable mais un business
qui est profitable
ça peut être c'est un business qui est
moral ça peut être un business qui est
responsable
ça peut être un
un business qui est respectueux et je
vois pas pourquoi on devra confronter
ses demandes et pourquoi on pourrait pas
trouver le meilleur est assemblé le
meilleur de ses demandes
je voulais faire un modèle avec avec du
sens et je j'ai envie de dire je m'en
fiche complètement de bouleverser les
habitudes d'aller ouvrir un compte
bancaire chez un buraliste
bien que ça surprenait tout le monde et
que tout le monde me disait mais tu es
fou ça ne marchera jamais tokyo
bouleversera les habitudes mais le but
c'est de cdo responsabiliser les gens et
de les responsabiliser pour les aider
parce que je pense que la meilleure
façon d'aider les gens c'est pas leur
dire mais c'est de leur donner des
outils qui leur permettent justement
d'évoluer dd je voulais faire quelque
chose vraiment de grands je voulais
faire quelque chose rien de nouveau mais
je voulais plus que tout faire quelque
chose de vraiment rigolo et je vous dis
que quand on s'attaque aux banques
c'est vraiment rigolo je voulais
vraiment faire quelque chose dont
j'étais fier à 200% et pour moi
franchement et aurait été impossible
il suffit d'oser alors l'économie
sociale et solidaire à ce que est ce que
c'est compatible
au départ quand les intervenants du camp
les organisateurs été dit ce qu'on
demandait d'intervenir le monde y brille
à fait contre michael ses trucs pour les
pauvres c'est bien c'est l'économie
sociale et solidaire
ouah je voulais faire un truc beau et on
me raconte c'est le truc pour les
pauvres économie sociale et solidaire
alors j'ai été l'ex est franchement très
honnêtement j'ai été vexé parce que mes
premières impressions je connais pas du
tout l'économie sociale et solidaire et
j'ai entendu que ça s'appelait le ss
donc on a même trouvé un sigle je
connaissais pas du tout mais moi dans
mon idée l'économie sociale et solidaire
c'est est vieux c'est poussiéreux ccba
dynamique s'est pas compétitifs
ça va demander de des fonds en
permanence et je n'étais pas tellement
je me suis dit alors c'est quoi sinon
pourquoi j'ai cette notion là pourquoi
j'essaie conscient qu'il me dérange
tellement pourquoi je suis pas content
déplacer là dedans parce que finalement
c'est très louable économie sociale et
solidaire
la première chose je me suis dit je vais
regarder tous les groupes sociale
pourquoi social se veut dire quoi social
veut dire qu utile à la société
est ce qu'on doit préciser que
l'économie doit être utile à la société
est-ce qu'on est obligé de rajouter
économie sociale qu'est ce que ça veut
dire se dire que l'économie n'est pas
social etc en rajoutant du social
finalement valeurs un peu plus un peu
plus agréable un peu plus un peu plus
avenantes
j'ai eu un autre sujet qui m'a dérangé
c'est le sel solidaire en juin qu'on
soit solidaires c'est super louable mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on a créé tellement d'injustices dans
cette économie qui va falloir qu'on
rajoute de la solidarité pour compenser
faire un une forme de démagogie récidive
il ya quelque chose qui il ya quelque
chose qui va pas et puis quand on parle
de solidarité c'est bien d'aider les
plus démunis les us clés etc
mais moi j'ai une question à poser et je
suis désolé mais qui paye tout le monde
comme vos impôts comme vos cotisations
d'insouciance qui paye les pauvres à
limiter en effet veiller toute chair les
frais d'incident les commissions
d'intervention les loyers le téléphone
etc et pour les riches
on a dit déjà utilisé ce parc est
partout et on va tous se retrouver entre
vos offres
c'était ça qui paye mais il faut se
poser la question et en économie sociale
et solidaire se désole meilleur de
l'économie il va falloir qu'on se cache
derrière mon petit doigt
l'économie c'est de l'investissement
investissement c'est l'argent c'est des
risques aussi on prend des risques en
trophées de l'économie
il ya des coûts via la rentabilité et du
profit et sa folle assumer de façon
décomplexée et tous et tout s'est ému
toute cette économie
il va falloir qu'elle soit supportée par
quelqu'un il va falloir aussi que
quelqu'un en profite et ça me paraît et
ça paraît logique mais le pire dans tout
ça quand j'ai vu l'économie sociale et
solidaire
je me suis dit c'est surtout je la veux
que l'économie elle est ni sociale ni
solidaire et là je me suis dit et si on
ils sont rééquilibrés cette économie et
si on arrivait à faire une finance this
way et sociale et solidaire et la jaune
qui dit chiche
alors j'étais tout seul au départ je
reste est tous un peu longtemps et puis
havrais à force de dire faille dans la
ligne andy murray est chiche
c'est un peu le jeu suit me convier tout
à l'heure c'est le deuxième qui voit là
est le troisième et le quatrième
aujourd'hui les 48 alors après ce les si
les derniers chiffres que j'ai se
confirme c'est ce qu'on appelle le
continuel de ce qu'on appelle un succès
et j'en suis j'en suis extrêmement fier
et je me suis dit je vais essayer de de
faire le chemin à l'envers de dures
batailles film et me dire là dedans il
ya eu quoi comme un gagnant c'était quoi
les ingrédients qui ont fait que cette
économie qui peuvent être social et
solidaire cette finance ou cette
économie tout court cette finance 3.0
puisqu'on parle de la société 3.0
parlons de la finance
enfin le rouge c'est qu'elles financent
2.0 qui existent mais j'ai pu bien ce
qu'elle fait j'ai pas bien regardé alors
je me suis dit on va passer directement
au 3.0 et on va voir qu'est-ce qu'on
peut mettre dedans
et la première chose qu'on doit mettre
dedans et plus que tout c'est pas la
motivation se voit de la volonté c'est
des convictions il faut être convaincu
sinon vous n'irez nulle part vous êtes
en train de faire des changements de
modèle on est en train de faire des
changements de modèles notre société est
elle en train de changer notre société
est en train de se réinventer
mais se réinvente plus par idéologie
elle serait à vendre par besoin et donc
si vous voulez rentrer là dedans si vous
voulez ouvrir la brèche la brèche
il va vous falloir les convictions la
deuxième le deuxième ingrédient qu'il
faut dans cette cuisine de soudan 3.0 il
faut de l'économie et l'économie réelle
la version 1.0 pas la version où on
gagne 10 millions avec deux clics de
souris et on perd 10 millions avec deux
clics de souris de la version avec de
l'économie réelle pas le troc la monnaie
la première monnaie qu'on avait celle où
on échange et cetera ou en gros
finalement on réapprenait avant d'un
service avec un profit raisonnable
en échange voilà dans cette finance 3.0
et la gelée j'ai entendu plusieurs fois
et tout le monde en est conscient
il va falloir convaincre la technologie
mais rien que la technologie 2.0 je
pense qu'elle a pas si l'on n'a pas
encore épuisé toutes ses capacités on
s'en aperçoive offert aux mesures votées
dick certainement et cette technologie
même existence on en n'a pas encore fait
le tour et donc cette technologie 2.0
pour moi elle est amplement suffisante
chez part de gens du 4g j'ai pas besoin
du paiement sans contact déjà qu'il
fasse par chef roger ça suffit j'ai pas
besoin de changer non plus un autre
point qu'on arrive à trouver
c'est un peu plus rares il faut chercher
un peu plus loin il nous faut des
talents si il nous faut des talents
parce que c'est grâce avec des talents
que vous pourrez aller loin et comme
j'aime j'aime dire c'est vrai que
souvent quand je suis tout seul je me
dise c'est bien je vais plus vite mais
mais quand on est nombreux
on va vraiment plus loin un point et
celui-là il faudrait que vous le gardez
au long de notre activité là c'est
l'audace il faut il faut jamais cesser
dosé de deux sentiments qui sont super
important en fait et qui vous permettent
de deux certainement de vote votre mal
en patience sans même vous rendre compte
que ces dits mal c'est l'inconscience et
la naïveté
il faut être sacrément inconscient est
sacrément
quand j'ai voulu créer les conti fiel je
m'étais dit on a commencé en 2011 mais
si ces trois mois brossage duré trois
ans et mais le problème c'est un peu
comme les balades en montagne
vous savez vous êtes parti pour une
heure était au bout de deux heures vous
on vous dit que vous n'êtes plus qu'à la
moitié quoi alors le dit et on fait quoi
on revient en arrière on continue eh ben
on a continué et j'ai continué comme ça
pendant trois ans et puis avec tout ça
et ça c'est vrai pour tous eh bien il
vous faut de la chance mais je vous
promets que quand vous avez des
convictions quand vous mettez l'économie
réelle quand vous mettez de la
technologie quand vous mettez tout ça
est bien la chance à dire vous et vous
pouvez vous n'avez plus qu'à la saisir
alors ça c'était pour les ingrédients
maintenant si on s'intéresse un peu ou
au mode d'emploi
je reviens sur ce que je dis et je il va
falloir oser oser toujours rose et c'est
un des problèmes de notre pays notre
pays il a peur de lui même plus personne
n'ose la réponse par des fossés c'est
impossible
moi quand j'ai dit on va ouvrir des
comptes bancaires dans des bars tabacs
on m'a dit c'est pas possible parce
qu'on n'a jamais fait comme ça on n'a
jamais fait comme ça alors donc c'est
pas possible on cancer atteint non non
faut continuer et il ya aussi des choses
que j'ai vu c'est que souvent les gens
quand ils cherchent une solution tout le
monde en gardant le même sens toujours
explorent des pistes ont déjà été
exploré moi je pense qu'il est bien un
truc qu'on doit faire c'est apprendre à
balayer ses certitudes et apprendre à
faire un 360 degrés autour de nous mêmes
regardez ce qui est possible sans a
priori ils sont et sans certitude 1 un
point qui fait partie de la finance 3.0
si on veut éviter les dérives et si on
veut éviter après dix mètres un côté
solidaire c'est qu'on va mettre de la
responsabilité et du respect maître de
la responsabilité et de respect ça veut
dire déjà au niveau du respect c'est à
dire déjà une égalité de traitement a
même servi ce même prix c'est marrant
dans la finance ça marche pas comme ça
quand vous n'avez pas d'argent vous
payer tous les découverts les âges les
frais d'incidents vous faites grande etc
quand vous avez plein d'argent votre
carte bancaire les gratuites à vie votre
tout on vous donne même de l'argent on
vous donne même de l'argent
c'est incroyable elle n'a pas une
égalité de traitement en fonction d'où
vous veniez en fonction de qui vous êtes
on va vous faire soit payé soit pas payé
moi quand je fais mon plein d'essence le
pompiste et me demande pas si je suis qu
alors si j'ai de l'argent j'en ai pas je
paye exactement le même prix est bien
dans la finance temps dans la finance
vous avez de l'argent vous payez rien
vous en avez pas vous payer tout et ça
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
immédiatement éliminé parce que sinon
vous créez de l'exclusion et si vous
créez de l'exclusion
l'injustice et quand vous créez une
injustice vous êtes obligés de rajouter
de la solidarité on doit être on doit
être responsable dans son dans son
service on doit être responsable sans
service en bois est responsable a
également dansé dansé serbie danser dans
ses tarifs parce que les services qu'on
doit fournir sa note des services
essentiels si vous regardez si je
m'interroge ce domaine de la banque
si vous regardez votre convention de
compte vous êtes bardet d'assurance vous
savez même pas ce que vous avez vous
avez des assurances perte de clés vous
avez des assurances et au prix de
mobiles vous avez des assurances etc
ça vous sert juste à rien retour à
l'essentiel retour à la case départ
de quoi j'ai vraiment besoin et moi
c'est ça dont je suis parti je suis
parti de là de la page blanche et du
besoin pour créer le technique et
ensuite dans notre propre fonctionnement
également on a un devoir parce qu'à
partir du moment où un vent un service
on doit vendre le meilleur service au
meilleur prix envie de dire donc dans
notre propre organisation de notre
propre fonctionnement
on a hâte de voir ces deux c'est
simplifier cette organisation d'arrêter
ses modèles complètement pyramidaux où
il ya un chef tous là où qui voit jamais
rien des sous-chefs en dessous et qui
passent leur temps à passer le bébé et
norbert en bas qui bossent voilà moi je
pense que maintenant il va falloir
arriver dans des modèles un peu plus
transversaux où il va falloir aussi un
peu con comme on dit qu'on remonte les
manches et que chacun commence un peu à
voir l'ensemble de la palette sur quoi
ils travaillent et de façon générale si
je devais trouver une phrase pour dire
c'est quoi être responsable dans une
entreprise est bon en fait c'est une
vendre un produit ou un service qu'on
prendrait soin ses parents soient ses
enfants et à partir de là si vous dites
il ya pas de problème je pourrais le
vent l'arrêt par an il n'y a pas de
problème pour elle vendra mes enfants à
partir de là il ya des grandes chances
que votre système à la base soit
responsable
un autre point qui est important dans le
mode d'emploi de la finance 3.0 c'est
l'universalité et ça ça doit être
inscrit dans le génome de l'entreprise
sociale et solidaire cependant il
l'appeler comme ça ou de l'entreprise
finance 3.0 ça doit être pour tous sans
distinction
ça je pense qu'on est tous des êtres
humains et je pense qu'on a tous le
droit au même respect nous conviennent
que tu conçois et en particulier dans la
banque et enfin sur l'économie c'est ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure il
faut aussi apprendre à s'adapter à
l'économie réelle
on peut pas se permettre d'en faire
l'impasse on a des bénévoles mais des
bénévoles
ça travaille tout le temps est-ce que ça
reproductible on vit pas d'amour et
d'eau fraîche
l'eau est payante l'amour bientôt donc
il va falloir vous vivez des salaires
vous payez des crédits vous payer des
loyers vous fait des cadeaux à vos
enfants vous mangez on a besoin de cette
économie
il faut pas se boucher le nez se laver
les mains en regardant cette économie
faut l'utiliser faut l'utiliser mais
faudra l'accord au faux-pas la pervertir
il faut un point important c'est qu'il
faut il faut sortir de ce diktat et on
est tous coupables et on est tous
responsables du low cost savez le bas
prix là on cherche tout au bas prix ou
pas prix parce que c'est ce bas prix qui
a fait que tout d'abord on s'est amusé à
sous traiter un peu partout sur la
planète à délocaliser comme on dit c'est
ce bas prix que nous aimons à chercher
parce que comprenez c'est deux fois
moins cher donc on peut en avoir deux
fois plus
ce bas prix finalement il ya un moment
il y a plus du tout il a plus aucune
référence
moi quand j'achète un lecteur mp3 à 5
euros maintenant comment c'est possible
surtout quand j'enlève la tvr et c'est
ce cette obsession du low cost qui fait
que des petits gamins de 5 ans seront
vos iphone mon iphone d'accord ils en
font 50 dans la journée pour un venez
c'est cette obsession du low cost hier
qui a donné ça et ça je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut sortir il faut
sortir de cette dictature de ce diktat
et de 7 et 9 collective moi je serais
plus d'avis à faire un ferr cost si on
veut parler anglais ou un prix juste les
choses elles ont un prix ça doit être
vendu et on doit avoir un profit il doit
être raisonnée il doit être justifiée et
doit être assumée et finalement une fois
que j'avais déroulé tout ça et une fois
qu'ils ont été aperçus que j'avais
écrits oraux à l'envers avec les
premières lettres et je me disais bien
finalement je suis tout à l'envers je me
suis dit mais en fait on est en train de
revenir en modèle et michaud on est en
train de revenir au modèle 11 un profit
raisonnable sur un sur un service vendu
ou rendu alors est ce que ça marche tout
ça c'est que tout ce que je viens de
dire ça marche je peux juste vous dire
une chose aujourd'hui c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ça fait neuf mois que le
contenu qu'elle est sortie on est à 50
6241 client a certainement un petit peu
plus qu'on a été de 18 à 81 18 ans que
l'âge moyen 40 ans et quand j'ai regardé
nos clients sur ses 56 méfiant qu'ils
étaient je m'aperçois que pour un tiercé
des employés première surprise pour un
autre tiers c'est des demandeurs
d'emploi c'est à dire des gens qui n'ont
plus accès à la banque qui sont
complètement
demandeurs d'emploi interdit bancaire
etc et je me suis dit finalement dans
ces dossiers-là ses deux tirs à la
jemaye j'ai mon côté social voilà à deux
tiers jeu si ce refus social
et puis dans mon dernier tir qui me
restait eh bien là je vois une myriade
une un panel d'utilisations divers et
variés qui vont aussi bien du cadre du
fonctionnaire des artisans des
entrepreneurs des seniors également des
retraités et des idées et des plus
jeunes voilà c'est ça pour moi c'est ça
la finance 3.0 et c'est ça que ça donne
à la fin et si la question et si la
première question de de cet exposé et
eve économie sociale et solidaire c'est
possible
la réponse aujourd'hui si je vais finir
par me répond c'est que c'est oui c'est
possible
je vous remercie